[Música]
una pregunta
a cuántos de vosotros
y levantar la mano alguna vez en la vida
la música os ha mirado
o sea mirado
poquitas manos de momento
y entonces a cuántos de vosotros nunca
en la vida a la música os ha mirado
bueno yo supongo que lo que estáis
pensando muchos es bueno
tendrías que explicarnos lo que estás la
pregunta es muy curiosa pero yo hoy
tengo el privilegio de venir a
explicaros primero que a mí la música me
ha estado mirando desde siempre que
hasta ahí pensaréis bueno ya lo sabemos
pero lo que os voy a explicar de verdad
es que en realidad a todos vosotros la
música os ha estado mirando siempre
y en la mirada de la música a mí me dio
lanzando mensajes a lo largo de la vida
me ha lanzado mensajes algunos me han
servido para mi labor como músico y
otros muchos para mi labor como persona
también y hoy os voy a explicar tres
mensajes que para mí quizás son los más
importantes y que son los que los que me
están guiando
vamos a por el primero yo empecé con
esto de la música muy pequeñito en casa
había cierta tradición familiar de
música con lo cual fue fácil que aquel
niño pues entrará en el conservatorio en
los primeros años de estudiar yo observé
dos cosas una que tenía ciertas
habilidades para la música
resolvió en los ejercicios que tocaba
con agilidad y la otra que observé es
que aquello se estaba convirtiendo en
una profunda vocación y que yo ante la
pregunta de qué mayor que quiere ser
pues yo decía quiero ser pianista quiero
ser compositor lo tenía muy claro y fui
creciendo con ello cuando eres pequeño
de datos y en mi caso también pequeño de
tamaño pues con 89 años haces muchas
gracias tocando el piano
y entonces a veces venía esa gente a
verme los familiares amigos porque
entonces no había la opción de que yo me
grabara y me pusiera en facebook o
youtube no me quería venir a casa
pero lo típico que está tocando algo
toca algo y yo siempre tenía preparado
alguna obrita de estas más o menos como
esta
[Aplausos]
aquí
y bien con esto yo triunfaba
yo tenía un amigo sobre todo cuando
hacía cositas así
era total tenía un amigo que me decía
antonio bueno es con el tembleque
y yo se llama trino esto se llama y pero
luego qué pasaba cuando cuando mis
amigos se iban y yo pues pues estaba
saboreando el éxito para escuchar yo
otros pianistas que eran referentes para
mí y para fijarme que salían muchos dos
pianistas cogía casettes discos de
vinilo y lo que quería escuchar de ellos
eran precisamente los movimientos lentos
los ansiosos dos lentos cosas como esta
por ejemplo
[Música]
y
yo pues me emocionaba y pensar cómo
puede ser que yo para demostrar que sé
de tocar mucho empecé a darle ahí pero
cuando a mí me demuestran que es también
tocan así y bueno fui creciendo con este
dilema y con muchísimos otros
y ya ha llegado a los 30 años casi
decidí que ya me tocaba comprar un piano
de cola porque yo en casa tenía un piano
de pared que era el que me habían
regalado mis padres desde pequeño y en
con 30 años tenía ya dos discos grabados
en el mercado como compositor y pianista
pensé yo creo que ya me toca y me fui a
madrid a comprarme un piano de cola y
llegué a lo que es un distribuidor de
pianos de cola que es es como un
concesionario de coches pero que en
lugar de coches hay pianos de cola
30-40 ya no es un pianista estar ahí es
un subidón es neurológicamente generas
la misma adrenalina que cuando un niño
de 8 años una niña entra por primera vez
en disneyland tú tienes ganas de decir
yo quiero vivir aquí si me pones un
colchón y un poquito de agua yo vivo
aquí total que yo iba a probar un piano
pero que tenía que esperar porque había
un señor mayor estaba probando un piano
y pensé bueno espero y estaba a unos
metros de él mientras él tocaba él
estaba de espaldas y yo en aquel momento
volvía a sentir esa emoción esa
sensación de pensar qué maravilla cómo
cómo toca este señor como me gusta qué
pasada
pero tocaba cosas así ese señor tocaba
cosas así
[Música]
y yo emocionado pensaba
es salir de mi entorno de mi ciudad de
donde yo triunfo con el tembleque y aquí
este señor mayor que debe tener mucho
dinero y que quiere un piano de cola
para el comedor de su carga con cuatro
acordes a bien está dejando emocionado
seguía mi dilema y eso se despejó rápido
porque este señor al cabo de dos minutos
acabó de probar el piano se levantó se
se giró hacia mí y me dijo cuando
quieras chico
y en ese momento le vi la cara y
reconocí que era el gran joaquín
achúcarro que es sino el más uno de los
más grandes pianistas de este país
y allí en los ojos de joaquín como suele
pasar con los grandes que sin decirte
nada me lanzo este primer mensaje y me
dijo toca despacio y emoción harás
rápido
y de regreso a casa me iba diciendo a mí
mismo anthony ha utilizado media vida
para aprender a tocar deprisa aprovecha
la otra media para aprender a tocar
despacio
y en eso estoy esta curiosidad por saber
el motivo de por qué nos emocionamos qué
nos ocurre aquí dentro
me hizo empezar mi labor como
investigador musical y empecé lo que
acabaría siendo mi tesis doctoral sobre
creatividad musical emociones y un día
estaba haciendo un café con la que era
mi directora de tesis y dar lago que
tanto aprendía de ella en las
conversaciones y me dijo mira anthony te
voy a explicar una anécdota que me ha
pasado esta semana con mis viejitos y yo
le decía como que son tus viejitos y
decime son esos ancianos a los que voy a
hacer clase de música en la residencia
yo así dividido y que les haces pues
mira hacemos ritmos cantamos bailo con
ellos qué interesante lleve días que
esta semana ha pasado muy curioso no
sabía que estaba tomada es tomás era un
viejito de 95 años en donde tomás ya no
sabía que se llamaba tomás y
me decía que este señor había decidido
voluntariamente cerrar los ojos llevaba
días así y el médico de la residencia no
le daba importancia a decir no bebé
perfectamente el día que quiera abrirlos
los abrirá bueno
y un de esta pila grafito clase de
música con ellos cantando y tocó el
turno de bailar con ellos se empezó
pilar hablar con uno hablar con otra
coge a tomás y empezó a bailar con él y
al cabo de unos segundos tomás abrió los
ojos
y ella se quedó sorprendido al acabar la
clase fue rápido al médico y le dijo
mira ha pasado esto y el médico le
insistió no le des importancia te dije
que los había cerrado y ahora los ha
abierto
pero ella sí que le dio importancia como
suele pasar con las personas apasionadas
y curiosas empezó a investigar habló con
la familia habló con los hijos analizó
lo que había pasado y descubrió que en
el momento que
estaba bailando con tomás la música que
sonaba era un pasodoble que tomás había
velado con la que había sido su mujer
cuando eran jovencitos
y en ese momento ocurrió
voy a hacer una pequeña pausa en mi café
compilar porque os voy a explicar una
cosa muy rápida aquí en el cerebro yo
digo siempre que funciona como un
ordenador como un disco duro y en el
disco duro tenemos carpetas tenemos la
carpeta de las fotos la carpeta de los
recuerdos la carpeta de los nombres de
las personas que conocemos la carpeta de
los datos de usuario
y lo hay una carpeta que es la carpeta
de los audios y en esa carpeta está los
archivos de audio es toda la información
sonora que ha entrado en nuestro cerebro
desde que nacemos incluso un poquito
antes en el periodo gestacional hasta
que nos morimos pues esa carpeta está
ahí permanentemente que ocurre cuando
viene una enfermedad una demencia senil
o un alzhéimer que es como un virus al
ordenador y empieza a [ __ ] las carpetas
que encuentra y llega a la carpeta de
las fotos al mundo a la papelera a
eliminar la carpeta de los recuerdos a
la papelera de los viajes a la papelera
las carpetas de los datos de usuario a
papelera al área no sabes cómo te llamas
y sigue el virus y cuando a buscar la
carpeta de los audios empieza a buscar
empieza a entrar y no puede
porque esa carpeta está blindada
el cerebro se resiste
a perder la información sonora que en él
qué pasó con tomás en ese momento cuando
sonó esa música ese pasodoble el
pasodoble esas ondas sonoras entrar en
la cabeza y el cerebro empezó buscar
buscar buscar buscar no me sale no me
sale no me sale no me sale no me sale si
me sale está ahí están atravesados los
audios está esa música ese pasodoble se
creó una conexión emocional y tomás
abrió los ojos y se emocionó
vuelvo a compilar
es respirar si me estás explicando esto
resulta que podemos afirmar yo le decía
esto estaba en época de tesis doctoral
con lo cual todo en la vida me apetecía
me parecía una hipótesis de trabajo
entonces podemos afirmar un subidón
llevaba
que la música cura del alzheimer y ya
está
y yo en ese momento la mire ya se me
quedó mirando fijamente y me dijo en
absoluto mi querido antonio y que si me
llama cariñosamente
la enfermedad sigue su curso sin piedad
y yo me quedé cascada
y entonces yo le pregunté si con la
música no podemos curar estas cosas para
qué vas
y ahí ella me dio el segundo gran
mensaje
me dijo porque mientras estoy con ellos
haciendo música
ellos son felices
y claro y en ese momento mensaje
entrante mensaje entrante antonio
mensaje entrante para que haces tu
música
para que te aplaudan rápido quedas al
tembleque
y yo hago música para que los que me
escuchen
después de escucharme se sientan mejor
y ese fue un cambio de enfoque total en
como yo pienso y como hago la música
seguí investigando y uno ya está por la
calle pensé
qué ocurrirá si yo un día soy ese
viejito de 95 años que no recuerdo quién
soy ni cómo me llamo ni que he sido
músico
cuál será la música que me abra los ojos
y empecé a hacer una lista
de canciones y tengo una una de las
primeras que puse que es esta
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la canción que yo escuché por primera
vez cuando tenía 11 años y a los 15 los
16 ya la estaba cantando y tocando por
ahí y ahora cada vez que suena pues se
prepara el mundo me emociono y me
transporto pero claro también pensé yo
soy compositor
debería poner en esa lista algunas
canciones mías
y pensé qué ocurrirá cuando yo tenga una
vida de 5 años no sepa quién soy y me
pongan una canción mía
será la primera vez que escucho una
canción mía
y qué canción y rápidamente vi que había
dos canciones que tenían que estar ahí
porque son dos canciones que las lleva
tatuadas aquí y son las dos canciones
predicado a mis dos hijos
unas semanas antes de nacer marc
yo pensaba como padre que le puede dar a
mi hijo
esa le podría dar una educación le puede
dar comida le puede dar dinero si lo
tengo
pero me di cuenta que había una cosa que
no se la podría dar de hecho nadie se la
puede dar a nadie la podemos desear con
toda la fuerza pero no la podemos dar
de la suerte
y puse título a esta canción suerte en
su art
porque pensé que
donde no pueda llegar yo
que llegue su suerte
y claro al cabo de dos años llegó ella
y cuando se cumple de nuevo el trinomio
del tapping compositor ñoño
pues le haces una canción a tu hija
también y claro esta canción no sólo la
llevo yo aquí
sino que además también la lleva a ella
ahora porque sabe que su canción y
porque además empieza a tocarla
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y el tercer mensaje va directo
va directo a ti que me estás escuchando
ahora
si aún no lo has hecho
empieza hoy mismo
y de hacer una lista de canciones
esas canciones que te transportan
las que te emocionan las catedrales que
separan el tiempo
porque si un día llega a ti ya no
recuerdas cómo se llaman las flores
habrá una canción
y su día no recuerdas cómo se llaman las
personas a las que has querido habrá una
canción
es un día ya no recuerdas cómo te llamas
tú
[Música]
habrá una canción
ahora que puedes
no lo olvides
aunque un día decida cerrar los ojos
la música
te estará mirando
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]